the vaccine effort across europe is
lagging behind the u.s and coveted cases
and some countries there are now spiking
some governments are imposing new
lockdowns chris livesay is in rome
chris here's a question how are people
dealing with this third wave
good morning gail remember a year ago
during the first wave and the lockdown
that happened
italians were at their window sills
singing songs and playing instruments
in solidarity but now as the latest wave
grips the nation
well the music has stopped it seems like
yesterday i was ordering a cappuccino
but today cities across italy are
locking down
again as a third wave rips through the
country
new cases and deaths are climbing due to
new variants and a shortage of vaccines
says deputy health minister pierre paulo
we have received less than 50 percent of
the expected losses
at the present time but i think the same
happened
everywhere in europe so it's not an
italian problem i think it's the
european
european program another european
problem
people letting down their guard as the
director of the cdc warned
this week these should be warning signs
for all of us
to make matters worse italy can no
longer use one of its most
available vaccines astrazeneca
after a growing number of nations
temporarily suspended it amid reports of
patients dying of blood clots
shortly after getting the shot italy's
medicines authority says
there's no evidence of causation and
halting the vaccine
is strictly a precaution just the latest
setback in a country that's already
suffered
so much we can't
stand this situation anymore today amid
its biggest recession since world war
ii and more than one hundred thousand
fatalities the military
has gone from trucking away the dead to
inoculating the living
if only the health ministry says there
was enough to go around
now since the start of this pandemic
things that happen in italy have had an
eerie way of repeating themselves
in the united states so if you're
worried about this latest wave coming
across the ocean well the health
ministry tells me
americans should feel very lucky that
that country
is vaccinating so quickly tony still
could be a cautionary tale for us chris
livesay in rome for us chris thank you
very much